talked a lot lately about the challenges
that are facing home buyers one thing
we've mentioned
is the cost of lumber is skyrocketing in
fact
one new home builder woodside homes has
fallen victim to lumber theft
costing thousands of dollars aside from
the rising cost of raw goods
sheer demand is making things even
tougher madison kimbrough joining us now
live tonight to explain
madison yeah denise we spoke to a
superintendent here at woodside homes
that says that lumber is such a hot
commodity right now
it's so hot that they have been struck
by thieves more than once
i've also talked to a realtor who says
that more and more people want
new home lots more than are available
new home inventory has been huge for us
this year
a lack of inventory tied together with
near record demand means getting a hold
of a new home site in some cases
is like winning the lottery literally
the builders are overwhelmed with the
demand that they're experiencing
so instead of creating these long lists
they are now doing a lottery system
which is the fairest way that they've
established
they can distribute the few listings
that they do have coming available
people are turning to new construction
because the resale market just
isn't what it used to be as homeowners
are staying put
many people are nervous because if they
do sell their homes they're nervous
about purchasing another home in this
market
they don't want to end up in a situation
where they don't have a home to live in
and with new construction homes they're
hard to build without materials
we had about 10 thousand dollars worth
of lumber stolen from this job site
actually
from this location where we're standing
right now mohader is the general
superintendent for builder woodside
homes and explains that because of
lumber's high demand
it's a common material to steal that
combined with the pandemic effect
it's making things tough they're right
when covets started a lot of the mills
shut down
and so that created a strain on what we
have so the demand of homes is high
we have a limited supply as mills are
opening up
they have certain protocols for covid
which we are now seeing that
that is reducing their their production
as of now hader says no suspects have
been caught but they've asked new
homeowners in the development
to keep a sharp eye out
and as you can see it's not just one
thing making it hard to buy home but
several now as for the site we were at
today crystal canyon community
that is in summerlin if you are
interested in any of those homes you
will be put on a waiting list
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now